senhoras e senhores educadoras e
educadores um bom dia
essa alegria essa descontração pode ser
nublado um pouquinho mas a gente tem
pedra depois então mais do laboratório -
auditório
a escola tem um tradicional mente é
privilegiado alguns verbos e advérbios
designações e os verbos que a escola
privilegia é copiar e repetido
muda se as tecnologias põe-se computador
na escola continua se copiam de
repetindo repetindo e copiam e os alunos
aprendem rapidamente essa dinâmica da
escola de tal maneira que se pede um
trabalho eles vão lá e copiam e colam
recorta e cola e chegar a um ponto em
que nem repete mais entrega para o
professor pra repetido desde então basta
espiar algumas obras de dois autores
viajei freire pra encontrar verbos de
altíssima significação e que superam
isso e que não são tão recentes assim
como interagir indagar experimentar
testar sentir cooperar descobrir
ultrapasar fala se tanto em impor
limites porque não se fala em
ultrapassar limites dialogar intervir
tomar consciência perguntar em sala de
aula que nem a pergunta é bem-vinda
refletir construir compreender
transformar inventar o piaget e dizia
assim
o problema que é necessário para
explicar o desenvolvimento cognitivo é o
da invenção e não da mera cópia inventar
não apenas copiar invenção é difícil
fazer em sala de aula como nós acontecer
bem se faz em laboratório e laboratório
pode ter múltiplas formas de ser
compreendido por exemplo uma aula de
matemática uma oficina de matemática uma
oficina de leitura de literatura
então o mamífero humano é um animal é um
animal é o único capaz de converter suas
ações em linguagem organizando
logicamente seus pensamentos
o animal humano é o único capaz de
apoderar-se do passado e planejar o
futuro
o animal humano é o único capaz de fazer
ciência e de tomar consciência pelo
menos a consciência auto biográfica de
que fala o neurocientista antónio
damásio ou a consciência refletida de
que fala piaget na sua obra abstração
reflexionar ante perguntas então por que
ensinamos os humanos como se fossem
animais quaisquer a serem domesticados
dentre tantas possibilidades nós
reduzimos tudo a copiar e repetir
daí a pergunta inevitável
como pode um professor ensinar
conhecimentos científicos se continuar
professando epistemologia senso comum
que são epistemologia o senso comum são
concepções de conhecimentos que todos
nós temos porque vivemos numa sociedade
numa cultura
só que nunca paramos para pensar o que
elas significam igual o impacto que ela
tem nas nossas vidas na nossa capacidade
de conhecimento
então é em psicologia no senso comum é
aquela concepção de conhecimento que a
gente tem
de parar para pensar a respeito
existem três modelos básicos
epistemológico brasil que analisar isso
o primeiro modelo aparece assim é
inteligente tem talento nasceu assim
epistemologicamente chama-se apriorismo
ele tem uma base nate sexta significa
fundamentalmente acreditar que a criança
quando nasci já nasce com todas as
condições de conhecimento
já está tudo ali só espero um processo
de maturação que vai aparecer é
inevitavelmente e isso vai acompanhá lá
pra vida toda como é que isso se reflete
na pedagogia como spanta neném isso
porque porque o professor disso eu não
tenho condições de modificar isso
o meio em cima não vai fazer nada a
respeito
com ela nasceu talentosa uma ser burra o
que vou fazer
então vou abrir algumas condições pra
ela ela assimila a alguns conteúdos e de
como é que isso aparece na sala de
professores nas nossas pesquisas e eu
tenho entrevistado com entrevistas que
duram aproximadamente uma hora mas 50
professores já publicadas
de onde vem a capacidade da criança de
compreender a noção de quantidade
pergunta se a esse professor de ensino
médio ele diz a inteligência nasce o
homem eu acho acho que ela já nasce um
disco mais outros com menos ela pode ser
desenvolvida mas acho que a gente já vem
com isso acho que a gente já vem ea
professora de ensino médio acrescenta
eu acho que saí uma coisa inata às vezes
têm crianças superdotadas já nascem com
aquele talento mas não são todas têm os
privilegiados mas nem tanto e o
professor de matemática veja bem um phd
em matemática pura universidade
importante do exterior lecionando para
graduação e pós-graduação em nível de
mestrado doutorado e no dia seguinte o
conhecimento matemático é muito difícil
ensinar poucas pessoas realmente
consegue a minha opinião sobre isso é
que consegue ensinar se a pessoa tem
talento e querer formar muitos
matemáticos de boa qualidade
simplesmente achando que a questão
ensinar para muitas pessoas matemática
não é uma boa política
não adianta muito e ele do alto de se
saber psicológico e lhe dá um
receituário pedagógico que ele diz assim
há três modos de aprender matemática
fazer exercícios muitos exercícios
segundo fazer mais exercícios muito mais
terceiro fazer ainda mais exercício
tanto exercício até se extremo chá no
chão ou seja para você aprender tem que
sofrer e muito e quando você vai para a
matemática pura então nem se fala
não namora mais não ver cinema é só
sofrimento
o segundo modelo epistemológico aparece
assim é inteligente foi estimulado
veja as matérias da mídia é sempre
estimulante estimulação resolve tudo
o estímulo é quando você olha para o
objeto não suja quando você olha pro
sujeito muda tudo
então ou ainda como diz um professor da
pesquisa é tudo questão de cultura quer
dizer o indivíduo é um produto da
cultura e ponto final
e se chama de empirismo como é que se
projeta na sala de aula um direitista
significa o professor comanda e o aluno
com mandato
uma das mais belas descrições sobre
instalar nas primeiras páginas do
pedagogia do oprimido do paulo freire ii
bem como isso aparece na sala de
professores
diz uma professora de ensino fundamental
quando tua braz uma árvore tem a noção
perfeita do que será futuramente um
cilindro aquele tronco do que seja uma
circunferência
creio que a criança pode ter muita
facilidade para matemática quando ela
tem experiências desse tipo eu
salvaguarda essa última frase que eu
acho que é impecável agora anterior não
dá para concordar
então veja bem como parâmetro
circunferência no sentido de uma
representação matemática eo árvores
errada o que é uma circunferência para o
matemático lugar geométrico dos pontos
de um plano que que disse um dia um
ponto fixo
o ponto fixo é o centro ea equidistância
o raio da circunferência
você vê isso no tron encerrado
então para o professor de matemática
empirista a idéia da circunferência vem
do tronco cerrado ou dos objetos que
estão por aí que sugere uma
circunferência
na verdade a ideia do matemático vem de
um mapeamento do infinito de situações
que ele leva à perfeição de tal maneira
que não existe estímulo equivalente a
natureza do qual ele pode copiar a
circunferência bem quais os efeitos de
uma pedagogia que funda a aprendizagem e
epistemologia do senso comum
o professor não compreende a
relatividade do conhecimento que ensina
o aluno não consegue compreender o que o
professor ensina desaparecem aos poucos
o desejo de aprender o interesse em
debilitar se a curiosidade o professor
sente se incapaz desanima ou refugia-se
no autoritarismo estéreo e destrutivo às
vezes no cinismo
aí está em um grande gênio século 20
eles não existe nenhum caminho lógico
para descoberta das leis elementares do
universo
o único caminho é o da intuição alugar
nas nossas escolas nas nossas salas de
aula para intuição alugar nas salas de
aula para experimentar indagar
conquistar autonomia tomar consciência
descobrir dialogar interagir refletir
perguntar construir transformar
inventado ou apenas para copiar e
repetido e daí um terceiro modelo que
aparece assim é inteligente construiu
foi desafiado ágil e refletivo esse
modelo crítica radical momentos
anteriores
chama-se construtivismo tem uma base
interacionista esse projeto na sala de
aula pode se projetar na sala de aula
como uma pedagogia da relação
um professor de escola técnica expressa
assim essa posição aliás é muito difícil
encontrar manifestações desse tipo se o
aluno está exposto a situações
interessantes ele se envolve ali está
brincando contigo e tu consegue
desafiá-lo propor algumas situações para
ler a capacidade de aprender é inerente
é o homem uma coisa do homem eu aprendo
quando tenho consciência sei que aprende
se isso é aprender então qualquer homem
tem capacidade para aprender porque tem
capacidade de ter consciência de que
aprendeu
é por isso que afirma
a escola precisa transformar se cada vez
mais em laboratório e menos em auditório
porque no laboratório e exerce a
intuição a experimentação formulam se
pergunta se hipóteses thomas e
consciência dialoga se instaura se a
interação transforma se descobre se
inventa se constrói esse conhecimento
numa palavra a sala de aula como
auditório tende a análise
as metodologias científicas pois
desconhece como as ciências produzem
conhecimentos novos e pensa que já está
tudo resolvido
piaget enfatiza essa ideia e ele põe
essa idéia como fundamental
toda a ênfase da minha teoria colocada
na atividade do próprio sujeito e penso
que sem essa atividade não é possível
digitar tica ou pedagogia que transforme
significativamente o sujeito essa idéia
portanto modifica profundamente a escola
uma escola que trabalha com a actividade
do sujeito não uma atividade comandada
mas recupera aquela atividade espontânea
da criança e do adolescente fora de sala
de aula
se a escola não consegue recuperar
aquela atividade dinâmica daquela
atividade ela não entende o que é uma
pedagogia ativa e acha que a ação é
aquela ação comandada então há certas
coisas que eu sinto mas me sinto
limitado para dizer com aquilo que eu
disse no começo e no fim a gente
descontrair um pouco
entrego então ao poeta para que o diga
e esse é o poeta todo mundo conhece que
diz sentir primeiro pensar depois
perdoar primeiro julgar depois amar
primeiro educar depois esquecer primeiro
aprender depois libertar primeiro
ensinar depois alimentar primeiro cantar
depois possuir primeiro contemplar
depois agir primeiro julgar depois
navegar primeiro a aportar depois viver
primeiro a morrer pouco depois
muito obrigado
o banco é obrigado